Hey everyone! We are back for a fourth installment in this series and here we are going to see the role that elasticity plays in understanding how total revenue comes about and understanding how a firm makes a decision based on total revenue: what they want produce? how much they want to earn? Let's go ahead and jump into it. The first thing that we need to do is define what total revenue is. Total revenue, you'll often see if the noted TR, is equal to price times the quantity. So let's just have a look at some sample prices and quantities that go with them. Let's have a price of $6, $5, $4, $3, $2 and $1.
And the corresponding quantities are going to be 20, 30, 40, 50, 60 and 70. Now we have our definition of what total revenue,yes, so let's go ahead and calculate out our total revenue. $6 * 20 is $120. $5 * 30 is 150 dollars. $4 * 40 is $160. 3 * 50 is $150. $2 * 60 is $120. And finally we have $1 * 70 which gives us $70. Now you will notice
that as my price decreases my quantity increases, so we have the law of demand holding. But then we also see our total revenue increasing and then all of a sudden it begins to decrease. So at $4 we sell 40 units,
and we have total revenue of $160. So from 5 to 4 and then 4 to 3 we see that we max out total revenue at $4. What does this mean? How can we use that? Alright, let's look at a few other items.
Let's go ahead and look at what we call marginal revenue.
Marginal revenue is just the change in our total revenue
whenever we change our output by some amount.
So our marginal revenue here MR is going to be the change in our total revenue as we change our output. So the easiest way to do it is just to have the change in the total revenue here. So 150 - 120 gives me marginal revenue of 30 whenever I drop my price from $6 to $5. When I go from a price of 5 to 4 my output increases by 10 and my revenue only increases by, or my marginal revenue increases by 10. Now, when I go from 4 to 3 my marginal revenue is actually going to become negative because my total revenue goes from 160 to 150. If I continue to drop my price look what happens to my marginal revenue. This is not what we want to see as a firm because now we are actually losing money whenever we continue to drop our price. So we want to find
a spot for our price where our marginal revenue gets close to zero--that is we cannot earn any more extra by selling extra units of output. Somewhere between $3 and $4 we are going to find that sweet spot. We're going to find where the marginal revenue is equal to 0. Now, let's do one other thing. Let's recall the elasticity of demand
percentage change in quantity demand over the percentage change in price. Let's add in the elasticity of demand for these different items. So for,
going from 5 to 6, uh, 5 to 4, and we're going to go from 4 to 3.
Here we'll go from 3 to 2 and then 2 to 1. So the elasticity are going to be -2.2,
-1.28, - 0.77,
-0.45 and then finally -0.23. So you'll notice we go from elastic demand all the way down to inelastic and then again there's this little sweet spot in between a price of $4 and $3 where our elasticity of demand would be equal to -1. What we are seeing is that when marginal revenue is equal to 0 our elasticity of demand is equal to 1 Where we are going to take the absolute value.
of that -1 to get us the elasticity of demand equals to 1. So this lets me know that if I have elastic demand, if I have elastic demand,so it's greater than 1, I can increase my total revenue by lowering my price. This also lets me know that if I have inelastic demand
if I have inelastic demand, so it's less than 1, I can increase my total revenue by increasing my price. Look what happens if I go from $1 to $2 my total revenue increased by 50, from 70 to 120. If I go from $2 to $3 my total revenue increases by 30. We go from 120 to 150.
Let's take a look at how all of that works.
We're going to draw when our graph here.
And we're going to have our demand curve.
Price and quantity. And let's just put in
uh, we'll put in $4 here and we had a 40 as our total being sold. Let's do $5.
And we had 30 being sold there and then let's do
$3,
and we had 50 being sold there. So we know that on this demand curve, at some point up to right here the elasticity of demand is greater than one, and then we also note on this demand curve
up to some point the elasticity of demand is less than zero. So that means on this demand curve in between 3 and $4 somewhere my elasticity of demand is equal to one. So if I want to increase my total revenue, and let me draw that in as well, so our total revenue curve is going to look something like this.
We'll have our quantity on horizontal axis. We'll have our total revenue on the vertical axis, and our total revenue looks something like this. And you'll notice that we have a maximum point right here.
This is the point where your marginal revenue zero and your elasticity of demand is equal to 1. Now how do we know where that marginal revenue curve is going to look like? Well I'm going to draw that in for us right now. Here, the marginal revenue curve is going
to do this. It's going to be below the demand curve, and we're going to drop straight down. So at this point
our marginal revenue
is equal to 0. Ok. Marginal revenue is equal to 0. That corresponds to this point right here. And let's just divide up this total revenue curve.
We're going to put a little division sign in there. And we're going to let this side of the total revenue curve let us know that the elasticity of demand is greater than one. This side of the total revenue curve let us know that the elasticity of demand is less than one. So if I want to increase total revenue and my elasticity of demand is equal to 0.5 then I need to raise my price.
If my elasticity of demand is equal to 0., ooh excuse me, is equal to let's say 1.5 then I need to lower my price in order to increase my total revenue.
One last thing that we want to look at,
and that is what we call the output
and price effects. The output
and price effects.
Let's draw this curve back in.
We have our demand curve here.
And we're going to put in some prices.
Let's say we have prices of 5 and we have
prices of four. This gave us quantities of 30 and 40 and at price, I'm just going to
do this table over still a little bit more here. So, 5 and 4 and we had 30 and 40.
This gives a total revenue of 150 and 160 and our marginal revenue is going to be
the change in total revenue as my quantity increases from 30 to 40.
Okay so let's see what these price and output effects are. The first thing that we're going to do is look at a price of $5 and quantity of 30, so this gives me this entire area right here.
That's going to be my total revenue for the area that's being shaded in right now. When I decrease my price from 5 to 4 my new total revenue is going to be this entire area here that I'm shading in right now. So what we see is a remainder. We have some revenue that we lost but then we also have some revenue that we gained. So we have the output effect and the price effect taking place. the output effect is going to be this OE for output effect. And the price effect is going to be this one PE for price effect. We lose revenue--the price effect--whenever we lower the price. But we gain revenue-- the output effect--whenever we sell more output. So the price effect causes us to lose 5 - 4 which is $1 times the 30 units that we were selling. So the price effect causes us to lose $30. The output effect causes us to gain 4 to the 0, so that's $4 times the 10 extra units that we're selling--the 40 -30. So it causes us to gain $40. So the $40 minus the $30 that we lost from the price effect gives us ten dollars that we gain by lowering the price which corresponds perfectly to the marginal revenue that we get by selling forty units at that new lower price. So that's how we bring in the marginal revenue concept back to what we see in this graph here. Again points to remember: the elasticity of demand is greater than one up to some point on this demand curve, the elasticity of demand is equal to one at some point on this demand curve and that corresponds to the important piece right here. This is where you maximize total revenue when your marginal revenue is equal to 0 and your elasticity of demand is equal to one. Alright, that's it. Hope you have enjoyed it and catch you on our final installment.